ومن العودة في أكتوبر، في معركة باري، قُتل ابن واحد
البندقية التي كانت داخل منزل كيبوتس باسي
وشهد على ذلك كوهين اثنان من الناجين من نفس الحادثة
أطلق شتانك النار على المنزل ونشره منذ حوالي شهرين
لتحريك هذه الوثائق الآن أعلن الجيش أنه سيفتح
في التحقيق في الحادث، سيتحقق مما إذا كان حيرام ناتان فرعيًا
Letzat الخزان هو الموجه لرؤيتي يسعدك
انضم إلينا بالتفاصيل ومع الاختبار
وقال: صحيح أنه ينبغي القول إنكم ستشنقون باراك حارم بالفعل
نفسه في محادثات خلفية مع الصحفيين قام بها بالفعل
تعليمات لإنهاء الحدث في أقرب وقت ممكن
ورؤية قذيفة داخل المنزل ولكن ينبغي التحقيق
التعامل في الواقع مع الطريقة الأكثر تعمقا للعملية
العميل الذي كان هنا لماذا وصلوا إلى هذا الوضع
قسم التحقيق في التأمين الوطني معروف بالفعل
نظرة فاحصة على محاولات الإسرائيليين لنزع السلاح النووي
النظام ولكن كان عليهم أيضًا أن يفركوا أعينهم عندما
هو أن هناك من يحاول ركوب إحدى الكوارث
الأعظم في التاريخ
البلد الذي اضطررت إلى الفرار منه لإنقاذ حياتي في الوقت المناسب
أن والدي عليّ ولدي البلاتين على قدمي ولا
تمكنت من الركض ووصلنا إلى محطة الوقود في سيارة أحد الأصدقاء
عند تقاطع طرق رأيت فوضى عارمة ثم أنقذها الجيش
وبعد بضع ساعات، طاردنا الإرهابيون
وبعد أصدقائي مات بعض أصدقائي أمامي
لقد أنقذت عيني بأعجوبة من ذلك اليوم الذي لست فيه
أستطيع أن أنام تقريبا
أعاني من القلق المذعور ولا أستطيع العودة
ويُزعم أنهم أرسلوا هذه الأدلة الدامغة لنفسي
المشاركون في الحفلة في التأمين الوطني حتى يتعرفوا على بعضهم البعض
فيهم كضحايا لعمليات الصندوق وبموجب ذلك سيكونون قادرين على ذلك
للحصول على أموال التعويض من الدولة ولدي علاوة أيضًا
غير ملائم
المستقبل لديه مشكلة صغيرة واحدة فقط، وهم ليسوا كذلك حقًا
لقد كانوا هناك بمستوى لم أتوقعه
أنت تقدر أن الناس يجب أن يكونوا قادرين على ارتداء الملابس
نفس القصة صعبة واستغلالها من أجل الإنتاج
بعض الربح من المعاش الشهري مدى الحياة
ومنحة أولية بقيمة حوالي 155,000 شيكل والتي تسببت
حتى بالنسبة لـ 150 ناجًا مزعومًا سارعوا للاستفادة من
الوضع نعم، التقى وزير الخارجية الأمريكي بلينك
في وقت سابق اليوم مع رئيس الوزراء وزير الدفاع
وكبار المسؤولين في الجهاز الأمني ​​وهناك يقول أودي
من بين أمور أخرى يمكننا أن نرى أنني صدمت
منذ أكتوبر وأنا مضطر لمنع شيء من هذا القبيل
يحدث مرة أخرى ولكن يجب علينا أن ندرك أن الواقع يقول
وزير الخارجية الأمريكي عائلات بأكملها لا علاقة لها
لحمس كان يتأذى كل يوم في حياتي سأسألك
وسوف نفكر أنا وأنا في آلاف الأطفال الذين قتلوا في غزة
هذه هي كلمات وزير الخارجية الأمريكي راش
حكومة نتنياهو تستعيد مسؤولية حماس التي تعمل
من السكان المدنيين هذا البيان كما ذكرنا
وأدى ذلك إلى إثارة دهشة بعض المسؤولين الإسرائيليين
وكان حاضرا أيضا في الغرفة أولئك الذين سمعوا عنها لاحقا
ثم يقول وزير الخارجية الأمريكي كجزء من الزيارة
كما أعرب هذا الشخص عن قلقه العميق إزاء النشاط الإسرائيلي
ممكن في رفح نحن الآن للتدقيق في الداخل
كابينة الحرب لنتنياهو حول رد فعله
الليلة، مايكل شيمش، كتبنا التفاصيل السياسية التي أنت عليها
لقد سمعنا جلب السيارات الهجينة من الخلف، انظر يا مايكل
رد بنيامين نتنياهو هذا المساء هو رد
من الواضح جدًا أنه يرمي بالفعل متطلبات
حماس بجميع رتبها، وكذلك وزير الدفاع يوآف
غدة الليلة، ولكن في معسكر المملكة ينتقدون
لكون ذلك حتى هذه اللحظة من لحظة قيام حماس فعلياً
لقد نشرت إجابته، ولم يتم إجراء أي نقاش حتى الآن
على المستوى السياسي الرفيع فيما يتعلق بكيفية الرد
وما هي التكتيكات التي يجب التراجع عنها في الرد على حماس؟
نحن نتحدث عن صفقة حساسة للغاية
وأضاف المختطف أن المصلحة الإسرائيلية هي في النهاية
اجعلها تحدث لذلك لم يكن هناك نقاش غدًا
ومن المتوقع مناقشة هذه المسألة في مجلس الوزراء
الحرب ولكن غدا فات الأوان ونحن بالفعل
ويمكننا أن نسمع التعليقات بوضوح هذا المساء
تسيزا كوت بالمناسبة الشركاء يجب أن أقول
كما يعتقد نتنياهو وغنان أن شروط
همس العرب هي شروط عبثية مستحيلة
لقبولهم، إذا كانت هذه هي الشروط بالفعل، على الأرجح
أنه من الأفضل تركها جانباً مهما كانت الانتقادات
يتعلق الأمر بالتواجد حول موضوع حساس كهذا
ولم تتم مثل هذه الصفقة الحساسة بطريقة منظمة